Hi, I'm John Green. Welcome to Crash Course Big
History. Today, we're going to look at the Modern Revolution.
Mr. Green! Mr. Green! But, what does modern
even mean. I mean, I know that fax machines
and Super Nintendo are modern, but like people
used to think that toilets that flushed were modern.
That's actually a pretty perceptive question,
Me From the Past, so if we are going to talk
about modernity, we should probably define
modernity. But first, I have great news.
There is a future, me from the past, where
video games are so much better than Super
Nintendo. In fact, this machine plays 24,000
games, and it is in the office of future you.
What were we talking about? Oh right, modernity.
So some historians date the beginning of the
Modern Era with the beginnings of The
Industrial Revolution in the 19th century.
Some date it to the French Revolution in 1789.
Some push it further back to 16th and 17th century
European colonialism. And, some date modernity
with the European Renaissance and call anything
past the year 1500 "early modern."
But through a Big History Lens, all of these
are just signs of acceleration in human collective
learning, which was already underway and took
its first tiny steps in East Africa 250,000
years ago. Then again, it would be silly to call the
first human foragers "Early-Early-Early Modern."
So for the purposes of today, let's say the
"Early Modern" period began around 1500, and
the "Modern Modern" period around 1750, with an
acknowledgement that it's all a little bit arbitrary.
And I know what you're wondering, but no, 1750 was
several decades before the first flushing toilets.
[Theme Music]
So, last week we looked at how Collective
Learning, which relies on population numbers
and connectivity to produce new ideas, grew by leaps
and bounds with the introduction of agriculture.
By the year 1400, the human population had
advanced magnificently, but the world was
still divided into four isolated world zones: The
Americas, Australasia, the Pacific, and Afro-Eurasia.
From a Big History perspective, what makes
the European explorations worthy of a place
in an episode called "Modern Revolution" is
that they eventually united all four world
zones into a global system. An increasingly
connected network of potential innovators
was great for collective learning.
But why did the Europeans feel so motivated
to expand? Well, a lot of reasons. One, Ottoman
dominance of overland trade routes with Asia,
particularly after the conquests of Constantinople
in 1453, made Europeans seek alternative routes
to the populous and rich lands of the East.
Two, European states were fairly small compared
to some of the vast empires of Asia, and needed
to compete for more resources to fuel their
almost constant wars.
And three, the fruits of exploration undoubtedly had
positive effects. Whether it be the many advanced inventions and
consumer goods imported from China, or the spices
of India and Indonesia, or crops from the Americas.
That last one should not be underestimated.
Crops like the potato, which earned the nickname
"Ready Made Bread" because it was easy to
prepare combined with maize, and squashes,
and tomatoes, and various yams allowed farms
in Europe to support more people.
This was also good for Asia where these crops
were introduced in the 17th century. And,
let us not forget about the vast amounts of
silver that the Spanish "acquired" from the
Americas, or the many cotton, tobacco, and sugar
farms that Europeans bolstered their economies with.
The unification of world zones also had many,
many negative effects. For instance, it was
terrible for people who worked on those cotton,
and tobacco, and sugar farms.
Europeans increasingly relied on African slaves,
the first of whom were granted to the Portuguese
by African rulers, and then you know, several
centuries of horror ensued with an incomprehensible
number of African slaves dying in the appalling
conditions of the Atlantic crossing.
Life was also pretty miserable for the slaves
that survived the journey, and generations
of their descendants. Also, because Afro-Eurasia
was a modestly connected, thriving cesspool
of disease, Europeans had developed many immunities.
When they started arriving in the previously
isolated Americas in the late 1400's and 1500's,
the indigenous inhabitants had no immunity
to those diseases. This resulted in one of
the most horrific events in human history. A cocktail of
various European diseases -- most notably smallpox --
killed off an estimated 50 million
people in the Americas in little over a century.
A similar tragedy played itself out in Australia when
Europeans started arriving there in the 18th century.
Now, along with all this horrific stuff, the
unification of the world zones was, nevertheless,
a good thing for collective learning -- which
would eventually prove our salvation in many ways.
And this global system continues to increase
in complexity and connectivity today. Which
is why people can now look at THIS on their
smartphone.
Anyway, the unification of the world zones
did not in itself lead to a breakthrough in
the way humans harvested matter and energy.
The last major shift happened with the arrival of
agriculture ten thousand years prior. The colonizing
European societies of the sixteenth, seventeenth,
and eighteenth centuries remained agrarian.
But the explorations did allow for a network
of exchange that eventually did lead to a
major breakthrough in how humans harnessed
more energy and produced more and more cultural
complexity, The Industrial Revolution.
The Industrial Revolution began in Great Britain,
as they'll be happy to tell you, in the 18th
century, but it was a global revolution involving
collective learning shared across the global system.
But a number of innovations that kick-started
industry originated in Britain, like the more
intensified use of steam engines, or the use
of coke to refine metals. Not that Coke, yeah,
that coke. Also, they invented many textile
machines, and Britain had lots of coal and
it was relatively easy to mine. Thank you
trees that died hundreds of millions of years
ago, we're going to turn you into industry,
and smog.
But all those British breakthroughs wouldn't
have been possible without a huge global network
of trade that supplied raw materials, like
cotton, and that opened new markets where
Britain could sell its goods.
And it wouldn't have possible to expand that
network of trade in the first place without
gunpowder, and the compass, which both came
from China. The methods of porcelain manufacture
that were important to the industrial revolution
in Britain also came from China via Germany,
and the improved methods of farming which
freed up many British farm workers for industrial
wage labour in the cities came from Flanders,
in the Netherlands. Early designs for steam
engines came from 18th century France, and
much of the designs for these machines depended
on mathematics preserved and transmitted by
Islamic and Hindu civilizations.
So up until the end of the 18th century virtually
all production in human history was propelled
by human or animal muscle power, or else,
by wind and water power. But it turned out
that coal and oil had stored energy from the
sun that had built up over hundreds of millions
of years, and using those resources dramatically
increased the energy that humans could harness.
Huge numbers of goods could be produced by
factories at relatively low prices which meant
that over many decades goods that had previously
been seen as luxuries by common people, were
suddenly viewed as necessities. By the 1900s
most Europeans enjoyed a standard of living
higher than the kings of the middle ages.
Coal and oil also allowed mechanization of
agriculture, which raised the carrying capacity,
increasing the population. And new modes of
connectivity beginning with the telegraph
and then later the telephone increasingly bound
the human species together allowing for swift
and rapid exchange of ideas. For 250,000 years,
if I wanted to tell someone who lived a hundred miles
away from me something, it took me days to do so.
For the last hundred years, it's
taken me seconds.
Because a slight tweak in modes of production
in the 18th century and the adoption of fossil
fuels led to an explosion of productivity
and invention in the 1800's and 1900's, people
often compare The Industrial Revolution to the
Cambrian Explosion about 540,000,000 years ago.
Remember, when a new skill or trait open
up new ways or 'niches' to extract energy
from the environment, evolutionary change can proceed
very quickly. In the Cambrian Explosion that
evolutionary change was biological. In The Industrial
Revolution that increased pace of change was cultural.
Consider bike design. In the 1800's there
were many many different designs for bikes.
Some of which look amazingly terrifyingly
unsafe. In the beginning of innovations for
bicycles a huge number of designs filled all
of the available niches. Eventually those
designs started competing with each other
and a few forms won out. You got the road
bike and the mountain bike and the BMX bike. Just a
little bit different variations of the same thing.
Another example is the adaptive radiation
of electronics. Take a look at all the stuff
you needed in the 1980's to do what your average
cellphone can do today. And that was only
a few decades ago. Many new ideas sparked
an increase in the human standard of living,
in the complexity of societies, in tons of
different ways. The explosion of cultural
evolution that started 200 years ago has yet
to cease.
The Cambrian Explosion went on for millions
of years. The Agricultural Revolution proceeded
for thousands of years. We're still right
in the middle of the Modern Revolution; maybe
only at the beginning. The huge shift in human
activity and a rise in complexity may continue
long after our grandchildren's lifetimes.
That is, so long as we don't do something
stupid, which, you know with homo sapiens
is always a distinct possibility.
And let's not forget about the rise in complexity
that's been happening since the beginning
of the universe 13.8 billion years ago. A
star is essentially a pile of hydrogen and
helium. It's extremely simple. By comparison,
a brain that arose via biological evolution
is an intricate network of billions of connections
and building blocks. Industrial society is
an immense whirring global network of millions
upon millions of brains, more closely connected
than ever before. The products of this society
raised complexity even further.
Bottom line is this: if the first part of
this series, which looked at the vastness
of the universe, made you feel insignificant,
just remember that now at the tremendous heights
of technological progress humanity is, in
terms of networks and building blocks,
the most complex system that we know of in the
universe.
And there's currently no end to the potential
for rising complexity in sight.
This brings us to a longstanding historical question:
"Why did The Industrial Revolution happen in Britain?"
Great Britain was certainly uncommonly
well-positioned. That said, so was China.
So why didn't The Industrial Revolution happen in,
say, Song Dynasty China, between the 10th and 13th centuries?
So we know the two main drivers of collective
learning are population numbers and connectivity,
and China has had both for a long time. The medieval
Chinese had much more advanced agricultural
methods than Europe; they paid attention to
weeding and growing crops in rows, and frequently
used tools like the seed drill. And they were doing it all
centuries before that stuff was even heard of in Europe.
In the 900's, the spread of wet rice farming
in Southern China raised the carrying capacity
even further because rice fields simply produce
more food. They are more efficient. Also,
rice is easier to prepare than the laborious
European process of turning wheat into bread.
So, during the 10th and 11th centuries, the Chinese
population increased from about 50 or 60 million
to about 120 million. That's a lot of new
innovators. So many, in fact, that Song China
came close to having a modern revolution of
its own. I mean, coal was used to manufacture
iron, production increased from 19,000 metric
tons per year around 900 CE to 113,000 metric
tons by 1200 CE. The Song Dynasty was the
first to invent and harness the power of gunpowder,
and then later, in the 15th century, Zheng
He conducted overseas explorations decades
before Columbus. Textile production showed
the first ever signs of mechanization in ways
similar to the European Spinning Jenny.
But. China had dry coal, while the British
needed to pump water out of their coal mines
in order to mine coal, which led the British
to build steam engines.
So, why didn't the modern revolution start
in China around 1000 CE? Well, it might have
been the cultural and political climate, and
a shift away from innovation and commerce
at the end of Song China in 1279. Possibly
because they hadn't united the world zones
in a network of trade and unified collective
learning. And possibly because the right combination
of cultural innovations required to launch a Cambrian
style explosion of growth just didn't happen.
The point is that collective learning is such
a powerful force that from the explosion of
the world population from only 6 million people
10,000 years ago to 954 million by the end
of the Agrarian era, the right combination
of ideas that led to the industrial explosion
might have happened almost anywhere.
So long as there are brains to think and exchange
ideas, so long as there are energy flows on
the earth, humanity has a tremendous potential
for rising complexity.
The modern revolution was accompanied by explosive
growth in human population. It took 250,000
years for humanity to achieve its first billion
people. By 1900, the world's population was
1.6 billion. Today, there are over 7 billion
potential innovators who are now connected
by the lightning speed of the internet, and
collective learning is more powerful than ever.
Humans now have unprecedented control and
power over the Earth's biosphere, which has
prompted some scientists and scholars to claim
that the Holocene is over and we now stand
on the threshold of a new era: the Anthropocene.
During this age, we may continue to raise
complexity in our little pocket of the universe
to wondrous new levels, hopefully to the growing
benefit of all humans rather than just a privileged few.
Thanks to collective learning, our potential
is awesome. Unless, that is, we hit a wall
like agrarian societies did every few centuries
when their population growth outstripped
their rates of agricultural innovation.
We are now in an era of immense danger, where
the modern global system of humanity might
exhaust the resources of the Earth, in the
same way that agricultural societies often
exhausted the resources of the field. More
on that next time.